(sighs)
Lucy, are we boring?
No, I'm not,
you might be.
-You know what we need to do?
-Hm?
Let's get outta here and
let's go on a group vacation.
-Yes!
-Get crazy, spice things up.
#
We could rent, like,
one of those big, fancy houses.
Remember the last time
we did that in Santa Barbara
and Todd cheaped out
on everything?
Oh no.
How is he even an adult?
So it's only $250 each.
Yeah, it's not bad, right?
Uh...I'll give you $75,
and then I'm gonna take
a little bottle of wine.
Are you haggling with me?
What are you doing?
What? It's free, isn't it?
We grabbed some groceries
from the store,
so you can just throw us cash
whenever.
No thanks, got my own.
You're gonna eat bacon
the whole trip?
Todd, we're going wine tasting,
you should probably
put some pants on.
How much does it cost?
Why are we friends
with him?
'Cause we love him.
Sweet meets savory.
Mmm!
And all of his
disgusting habits.
Ooh, what about skiing?
Remember the last time
we went up north?
-Milo and his baby bladder.
-He's like a Chihuahua.
Oh, you know what though?
Vegas isn't that far.
Except I'd have
to lecture Ben.
What, has he been gambling
or something?
Oh no-no-no,
it's a packing thing.
-What do you mean?
-Every time we stay in a hotel,
he brings our entire house.
-Oh.
-Hey, what's goin' on?
We're going to Vegas
for a night.
You know that most hotels
provide bedding, right?
-Yeah, it's Vegas though.
-Yeah.
Oh, but good call on the
skateboard and the teddy bear.
Could you grab this
so I can get my arm out?
Yup.
Is this my college backpack?
That is...insane.
I love my husband, but maybe
it should just be you and me.
As long as we can have
separate rooms, which...
-What?!
-...we'll make sure happens
because this.
Man, that's a medical condition.
#
(screaming)
(all screaming)
She sees dead people,
doesn't she?
I knew it.
Calm down,
she's having a night terror.
(yawns)
(screaming)
Do you remember this?
You sound like a monkey
being murdered in the woods.
Well, how 'bout the time
we put you in charge
of the room reservation
the last time we went to Vegas?
I remember a fun night.
I'm very over it!
Hey guys!
Can we go to the hotel now?
Um...you guys,
the funny thing is
is that I booked the hotel
for the wrong night.
We can't get it
'til tomorrow.
You know what?
Things don't close in Vegas.
You know what they say?
Motel, mo' problems!
-No.
-They don't say that!
It's not that big of a deal.
Maybe we should just stay here
and cook.
(laughing)
Oh, don't turn that oven on,
there's shoes in there.
You keep your shoes
in your stove?
We gotta make closets, you know?
Look how tiny this thing is.
We could make, um,
shoestring French fries.
Nope. No. Stop it.
-I got more.
-I can't handle it.
These shoes are made
for baking.
No. What is wrong with you
today?